so i'm really delighted to introduce
lyanna chua who is a reader in
anthropology at brunel university in
london
she received her phd in social
anthropology from the university of
cambridge
where she also held a research
fellowship in anthropology
she has worked with rural bdayu
communities in sarawak
malaysia and borneo since 2003
looking first at christian conversion
and ethnic politics
and more recently at displacement
environmental change and world making in
the context of dam construction
and resettlement schemes now she's
turning her research
trajectory towards uh more than human
engagements in borneo
focusing on some of the ethical dilemmas
associated with
orangutan conservation um
she's widely published and has a lot of
wonderful uh
articles and books that i recommend you
all look at um
her book is called the christianity of
culture
conversion ethnic citizenship and the
matter
of religion in malaysian borneo which
was published in 2012
she's also the co-editor of a volume
called distributed objects
meaning and mattering after alfred gell
which was published in 2013
and her articles are really quite
wonderful i'll just mention a few
there's a lot of them
there's one called the troubled
landscapes troubling anthropology
co-presence necessity and the making of
ethnographic
knowledge published in the journal of
the royal anthropological institute in
2015
there's an american ethnologist piece uh
from 2012
called conversion continuity and moral
dilemmas among christian bedaz in
malaysian borneo and also a wonderful
piece called to know
or not to know practices of knowledge
and ignorance
among vidalia's in an impurely christian
world
also with the journal of the royal
anthropological institute
today's session will be kind of a
special
experiment in um academic presentations
i've asked lyanna if she's willing to
engage in a kind of
a talk show style format the goal is to
introduce her work to all of you
and to allow her to chart some of the
themes that have been going through
these many
interesting connections and to introduce
the importance of
malaysian borneo um to a wide
interdisciplinary audience of southeast
asianists and also people interested in
anthropology
so the way this is going to work is
we'll have a conversation
for about 20 to 30 minutes
and then after we do that i'm going to
open it up to questions from
from the whole audience and i've asked
lyanna to kind of
speak broadly in a way that can bring
people into her work so even if you
haven't read her work yet you'll get to
learn a little bit about it
along the way um so with that said let's
turn to um
the the conversation um so first
thank you liana for joining us and it's
really delightful to have you here
hi it's nice to meet everyone and thank
you very much for such a lovely
warm and generous introduction eric it's
really nice to meet you
yeah so it's great to have you um i want
to ask you
um about the places you work in in
borneo
and some of the people that you've come
to know in your field work so you know
if you could just kind of speak in an
open sense about
where where do you work and who do you
work with and what are some of the major
issues confronting people in the region
and you know what are some of the core
themes that you see animating your work
and how they've emerged from your
long-term research in malaysia and
borneo sure okay thank you yeah so um
i guess i sort of see myself as an
anthropologist of borneo and in the kind
of broadest sense
um in the sense that i tried to approach
borneo as an island that's you know very
much a sort of interconnected space
um with with many sociocultural
linguistic
religious political formations but also
environmental events and
and um processes and changes that
transcend uh contemporary
national boundaries um so in that sense
i'm very interested in the sorts of
flows and connections but also kind of
gaps and tensions that go on
within this broad island um but having
said that the the bulk of my research
um since 2003 has been with um
bidet use um as eric mentioned so um
badays are a small indigenous group uh
they live in the
east malaysian state of sarawak in
borneo and they live in the sort of
mountainous hinterlands of the state
capital kuching um and so for my phd
i i lived for about 15 months which is
fairly standard for anthropological
field work
in a fairly large pideu village and this
village was a really interesting place
to be in because it was in the middle of
this transition
from a kind of rice planting animist
past to a very self-consciously
modern urbanized christian present and
future and i kind of turned up towards
the tail end of that process
um and one of the most interesting
things about doing research at that time
was that although the vast majority of
people had converted to christianity
various denominations of christianity by
that stage
many of them still remembered what it
was like to do the old rituals um you
know they had sort of first-hand
experience
of what it was like to convert to
christianity relatively recently kind of
in the last 10 20 years
and so there was that you know there was
this kind of really rich living archive
of the conversion experience
but there are also about 10 elderly
animus practitioners who are still
carrying on and still doing the old
rituals
and actually being helped in various
ways by their sort of younger christian
kin and neighbor so it was a fascinating
time to be there
and so that was what eventually gave
rise to my book um and some of my
earlier publications
on christianity where i kind of looked
at how bidet's experiences of converting
to christianity got
kind of enmeshed with their experiences
of contemporary
ethnic religious politics in malaysia
which you know as many of you know is
dominated by a kind of malay muslim
majority but also how this was impacting
on their own internal relations within
the village and the ways they were
negotiating
their relationships with both the old
animus practitioners
and the old spirits were still very much
around and very present in their lives
um and so i've written about that um and
maybe we can talk about that a bit later
on
um so that was my phd um after my phd
from about in 2007
um i began doing what turned into a
quite a long-term project
i'm still doing it um that traces the
experiences of four
small and relatively remote video
villages that got caught up in a damn
construction and resettlement project
so i've basically traced the experiences
of these communities all the way from
the sort of preparations you know when
they were thinking about compensation
who was going to go where who was going
to move to the resettlement site
to um a very sort of fractious and very
protracted legal case that some people
fought in order to prevent being moved
to the site and
they wanted to move up to a new site on
their ancestral land above
above the dam all the way through to the
inundation phase
from about 2015 onwards and now i'm
looking at the inundation phase where
you've got these people
including three very small villages that
are in fact now above the dam as they
were hoping
um who are really struggling to kind of
create new and livable futures for
themselves
in this new space where actually there
was no there was no real
they weren't really meant to exist in
these spaces you know in these kind of
brand new
um wooden villages that were built above
a major
development project they were never
meant to be there and so it's been
really interesting kind of writing about
these experiences and i'm now trying to
work on my second book which will be a
sort of more than human ethnography
um you know of of how these these
different affected villages tried to
navigate their relationships with each
other but also with a developmentalist
state
with um various indigenous rights
activists and lawyers who got involved
in the case
um with different christian churches who
all had very different kind of spiritual
and
political stakes in the situation and
also with place spirits and with a
changing landscape and with the
christian god i mean these were all very
sort of active players
um during my field work and and i found
a kind of more than human lens
a very useful way of thinking through
these extremely sort of visceral
um very sort of material experiences so
that's the post update um and also my
current work
but um what i'm actually doing right now
is a sort of extension of
this earlier um interest i guess in more
than human anthropology
um but also the ways in which
uh rural and indigenous communities in
borneo engage with
global movements um and and kind of
entire complexes so so at the moment um
i've got a couple of projects going um
on the global nexus of orangutan
conservation
um uh the first one is a fairly sort of
classic
anthropological multi-sited exploration
of how
the different bits you know people
things ideas of this of this
conservation nexus kind of move around
shape each other shape realities on the
ground or very often fail to there there
are many tensions and conflicts within
this um this network as you can imagine
um and so i've got i've got a team of
researchers working with me i can talk
about that a little bit
and what we're trying to do is basically
um use in-depth anthropological research
at different sites of orangutan
conservation you know ranging from
little villages
caught up in wild orangutan conservation
schemes in central kalimantan in borneo
to orangutan charities in the uk that
are raising funds for these schemes
um and we're trying to sort of build up
a more kind of holistic picture of how
this one conservation nexus is or isn't
working
um against the backdrop of the
anthropocene and that's a whole other
discussion um
that we can have later on so that's one
project um the second project is
um slightly more um
unusual i think for for an
anthropologist it's it's a more sort of
applied
anthropology conservation collaboration
um where i'm working with eric mayor
who's
quite a senior orangutan conservation
scientist and we're basically trying to
use
um ethnographic insights and methods to
devise better ways of
mitigating orangutan killing in rural
borneo and
and more importantly for me to try and
help conservationists to
engage better with local communities in
more kind of contextually specific ways
um so those are kind of you know the
three main bits of my research
trajectory
um i mean in terms of the core the core
themes i think you know maybe
i've already touched on them there's a
sort of enduring interest i have in
in more than human interactions and and
by this i include everything from
objects and plants and animals
to spirits that you can't see um and i
think i
am also very interested in trying to use
a sort of grounded perspective you know
in-depth
ethnographic research that takes local
concepts and experiences seriously
as a way of cutting you know these these
big
ideas like the anthropocene or like
development or christianity down to size
and to try and understand the kinds of
local faces that they acquire um on the
ground so
yeah that's a sort of quick that's a
really quick overview of what i'm doing
i was muted uh it's fascinating to hear
you just
walk us through the the broad trajectory
of all your research
um there's so many um tangents that are
all entangled around these these core
ideas of the more than human
um i'd actually like to hear you talk a
little bit about
what you see the contribution of more
than human anthropology
um doing because it's it's it's rising
as a
as a field these days but i also would
like to ask you because
in some of your writing you've developed
some critiques
of the ontological turn um
and let's be mindful of the audience not
everyone in the audience will
necessarily
be an anthropologist per se and so if
you could
explain the connection to your critique
of the ontological turn
sort of situate that a little bit
explain what you think they're doing
and um why you're a little bit hesitant
about some of the aspects but also
inspired
it seems to me by the by them a little
bit too and then also
talk a little bit about what you think
the importance of the more than human
turn
in anthropology is too
it's a lot so you can separate you can
talk about only one of them if you want
but
well i mean i'll start with the
ontological term but just kind of you
know give me a push if i if i forget
about the other bits
sure yeah so um wow where do i start
okay
so the ontological term is um
essentially a sort of
movement or well let's call it an
umbrella term
um that draws together a bunch of very
different approaches that emerged in
and beyond anthropology you know across
the social sciences and humanities
around the late 2000s or mid to late
2000s and that was
most strongly articulated um by a group
of scholars in about the late
2000s early 2010s and particularly a
group of anthropologists from cambridge
at the time
um who actually uh came up with the with
the phrase the ontological term so what
they did was they kind of drew together
all these different
developments which were connected as
they saw it and gave it a name and said
you know this is
the future of anthropology and so
essentially um
what these anthropologists argued at the
time
was that up to that point
anthropologists
had failed to really take seriously we
use this term and not take seriously
um the various beliefs you know
political concepts experiences of the
people that they worked with
because they were they were unable
to apprehend these beliefs and concepts
and practices and so on
on ontological terms which is to say
that if for example you saw a bunch of
um if somebody told you that you know
that that cape is my ancestor
or that power that powder is powerful
you as the kind of you know cartesian
rational anthropologist would say well
that's just a kind of that's a cultural
gloss
of um an ontological reality that's
that's not really
power that's just powder that my
informants
believes is power or you know that that
cave is not really an ancestor that's
just a kind of you know
that's just a material object it's just
that they believe that this is their
ancestor
and so proponents of the ontological
term basically argued that this sort of
smarter than thou as one of them put a
tendency
um was actually um you know not not a
very ethical way of doing anthropology
but also not a very conceptually
creative way of doing anthropology
because you were then always going to be
sort of hamstrung
um by your own kind of ontological
schema and your own assumptions which
meant that it would be impossible
to fully engage with these um with these
different
you know these different people and
concepts on their own terms
and so in place of what they saw as this
very inadequate concept and i should say
that i don't think they were entirely
fair either about sort of criticizing
previous generations for not taking
people seriously
um but in place of what they saw as this
this kind of flawed
approach to anthropology they they took
a sort of deliberately naive approach
which basically aimed to take their
interlocutors concepts
words beliefs at face value
on onto logical terms so you know if you
say that cape is your ancestor
in your ethnography you say um you don't
write
they believe that that cape is their
ancestor you just say that cape is their
ancestor
and you run with it and then from that
point on you know once you've kind of
made that that sort of ontological
leap and started to engage with these
local um
you know other radically different
concepts on their own terms
then the so the whole sort of process of
conceptual creativity and theoretical
creativity could begin and that was
for ontological turn proponents that was
the kind of most exciting bit of
anthropology that point where you
you confronted this radical alternative
you had your own presumption shaken up
and then you came to this new um this
new and exciting understanding of the
world or this concept or belief or
whatever
and then wish you were off right and
then you could sort of talk to other
anthropologists about what you found so
that's essentially it
um so i think in many ways
um the ontological term is
does provide a very useful kind of
methodological um
and analytical approach to
anthropologists especially of southeast
asia where you know as you know
there's a huge amount of heterogeneity
that there's so many different sort of
linguistic cultural religious complexes
so many different kinds of social
social formations politics and so on
that are also coexisting with very very
strong and very influential homogenizing
forces
like states um nationalist movements um
you know sort of orthodox islam orthodox
christianity
um all of which have a sort of tendency
to to suppress that heterogeneity and
you know have a tendency to just kind of
squash
um that sort of difference in the
interest of creating a more kind of
purified or
or unified whole and i think in that
sense you know
maintaining that sort of ontological
attorney
impulse i guess ontological attorney
yeah anyway that impulse
um you know to kind of push back against
homogenizing forces to avoid explaining
things away by recourse to your own
concepts and your own values
um can be extremely useful to
anthropologists of southeast asia as we
grapple with all these kind of different
possibilities different life worlds you
know just kind of different ontologies
you might argue
and actually here i think we might you
know maybe learn a thing or two from
people like marisol de la cadena you
know another sort of contributor to more
ontologically inflected anthropology
um with her work on indigenous
cosmopolitics in the andes where
she does in fact try to you know adopt
her to kind of engage with
with these radically different concepts
on their own terms so so that's the kind
of
you know that's a very quick summary of
the ontological term and why it might be
useful to
southeast asianists um but you know as
eric you noted um i do have some
concerns with the ontological tone
so i'm going to try and summarize them
really quickly um
i think my first concern is that
um even though let's call them
ontologists um just for sure right even
though
ontologists do say quite explicitly that
they're not trying to
sort of reify otherness and difference
they're not going out there looking for
you know um
sort of noble savages or exotic others
or whatever they're saying
it's about anything that anything that's
unfamiliar or different that sort of
challenges your preconceived notions
counts as authority so even though
they're not explicitly saying that
they're looking for a radically cultural
other
i think in practice what an ontological
approach tends to do
is replicate um a dichotomy that
has kind of haunted anthropology since
since its inception which is that
dichotomy
between the sort of western you know
implicitly cartesian
euro-american self with with all its
baggage
um and the cultural other so when you
start to read quite carefully you know
what what ontologists are writing
even though they never explicitly talk
about this being about
otherness and and you know radically
different people
their work is implicitly addressed
towards
a we that is composed of um people
who are assumed to have a kind of
western cartesian background
anthropologists for whom that kind of
leap of of understanding um
you know is really really difficult
because they're facing such radically
other concepts and those radically other
concepts always seem to be
anti-cartesian
um you know or just just kind of these
conceptual foils to western
to a very hackneyed understanding of
what western thought is
um as you can imagine i i felt
personally quite uncomfortable with this
as well as a sort of
um singaporean anthropologist who didn't
necessarily see myself or kind of
recognize myself as part of that
that us um as opposed to that them so
you know when i was doing field work in
um in the village for example when
people talked about spirits living in
trees and little demons that could
you know suck your blood you know all
these things i've grown up with this
stuff
it was not it was not a huge conceptual
leap for me to understand
what was going on and to take this stuff
seriously i didn't need to explain these
away i mean i felt i got these shivers
you know when people talked about these
things because i recognize them
so i think there is that problem that
you know even though they don't
necessarily explicitly try to
there is a tendency to kind of fall back
on on this rather problematic dichotomy
with an anthropology
um and i guess sort of linked to that is
that
i do have some concerns with the
position and the role of the
anthropologist
um in in the ontological turn
um and i and this this was very much the
basis of my critique in the
troubled landscapes uh paper that you
read eric um
where what what you're essentially doing
by kind of
privileging that encounter between the
anthropologist
and that moment of radical alterity that
that sort of unexplainable
you know unfamiliar moment where your
whole world gets kind of blown apart
what you're kind of doing i think is
inadvertently centering the
anthropologist
and you're basically turning the
anthropologists into this kind of rather
invulnerable
you know impermeable arbiter um who has
the complete uh capacity and thus
authority
to decide which concepts which beliefs
should and shouldn't
be treated on ontological terms you know
which of these
you're going to run with as the basis
use of your kind of conceptual
um creative process and and i guess my
problem with this is that it tends to
sort of purify the field work encounter
it it sort of it strips away you know
all the all the confusion the
mistranslation
um the misunderstandings the tensions
that you inevitably encounter in the
field
um you know there's so many times when
i've been i've been told something by my
friends i've taken it really seriously
i've written it down
and then the next day they're like oh by
the way that was just a joke you didn't
really believe that did you that thing
about spirits
um and you know you get so much of this
in in the field
um or you get people kind of
deliberately pulling you into their own
you know political projects and kind of
making up all sorts of things that will
you know boost their
their position whatever right so so
there are lots of these kind of
little you know messes and complications
of co-presence
as i call it that you will find within
the actual experience of field work
that kind of gets stripped away when you
start trying to approach
things in this deliberately naive manner
um and so what i guess i was calling for
in this um
troubled landscapes paper was was
basically um
a more a sort of more humble approach um
to anthropology
that that didn't just kind of shine a
spotlight on the anthropologist
and and kind of privileged the
anthropologists as the locus of
all that was exciting in anthropology
you know once you've got these wonderful
concepts off you go
you know go talk to your mates in the
ivory tower and kind of make up new
theories great
that was precisely what i was trying to
avoid and i was what i was basically
saying was no we need to try and ground
these encounters
in the networks of co-presence um in the
field which we can't afford to erase
from our ethnographies and and of which
we are inevitable
inevitably part um as anthropologists
so that's kind of where my um discomfort
with the ontological
term lies so that's no that's really
this is fascinating the thing that i
find so fascinating about
your and what you've just described is
that your critique of the ontological
term
quote unquote take seriously the impulse
of the ontological term
which which they claim in some ways is
to
um you know take seriously other
perspectives but then you recognize
in the process it's inadvertently
privileged the anthropologist so it's a
very interesting
critique that you know is is sensitive
to
the ambitions of the turn um but also
recognizing its internal contradictions
which is quite interesting
i wonder if you could take us into
borneo a little bit
and in that in that essay where you're
talking about this
and describe a term that you use in
there
you you say there's a risk in the
ontological term
to have a proclivity to gloss over local
heterogeneities
which i found really gripping because it
reminded me of my own field work in
southeast asia where there's
lots of heterogeneities and whenever you
want to claim that there's a kind of
a an ontology of something it can be
quite tricky
but i wondered if you could describe a
couple of the heterogeneities that
maybe like let off a light bulb for you
or something like that
and then after that we'll turn to talk
about your orangutan work and then
after that we'll open it up to questions
from the audience
okay great thank you yeah um yeah
absolutely so um this this kind of goes
back to my
earlier point i guess about how you know
ontologists
kind of hold i guess they privilege that
moment
of encounter yeah between the
anthropologist and the radical other the
old territy
and that's kind of like the the moment
you know when when everything
gets really exciting so you you kind of
you would often hear
you know ontologies saying um in person
i'm not really that interested in the
kind of boring everyday stuff
uh you know i i just i'm just really
interested in that unusual moment
because that for me is the most
important thing
um and i guess one of the one of what
shoots or
one of the consequences of keeping that
that encounter you know that interface
between anthropologists and other
at the forefront of the ontological turn
is that that whole other bit gets
squashed in the same way that the whole
sort of anthropologist
gets squashed right so there's another
sort of edited volume
um i recently did called who are we
which is um which was very much about
trying to question this
this rather un unthinking you know um
unproblematic invocation of the the the
sort of anthropological we as the
imagined
audience um you know who exactly are
this we that we're talking about anyway
that's anthropologists so we've got the
sort of local heterogeneity here
um yeah so there were many many moments
in the field where um
you know i sort of encountered these
sorts of divisions um
and this is this was precisely what made
me quite suspicious um
of any sort of program that tried to
make vast sweeping statements about the
bidet or about indigenous people as a
whole because this was
you know it was i feel like a bit of a
kind of um
misery misery guts but you know it's
it's it's very very difficult to kind of
run with those projects when when you're
very aware of the ethnographic
complexity and the messiness of what's
going on on the ground so one example um
which i mentioned was um
different christian views of um of of
the old
people you know the old animus
practitioners and the old spirits that
were still around um which i talked
about in this
other paper um eric which you read um to
know or not to know
and this was a really interesting sort
of tension that i encountered in the
field which was what on earth do you do
with these old guys who are still
insisting on practicing the old rituals
um you know how do you deal with the
kinds of spirit realities that these
rituals bring to the village because
the thing that you know everybody
understood was that
even though most people had converted to
christianity the old spirits were still
there
um you know they as long as people
continued
believing in them practicing the old
rituals doing things that would engage
with them
the old spirits would stay around um
they were they were less powerful and
less influential now because everyone
was most people were christian as they
said
but they were there and that was a
problem um because um
you know a lot of christians didn't
necessarily want to get embroiled in in
relations with these old spirits um and
so
one of the interesting things i found
was that uh christian's views of the old
spirits and the old rituals varied
according to their denomination which i
wasn't expecting
because you know coming in from the
outside i i had a very kind of dim view
of missionaries i just thought yeah
you know um nasty bunch um you know
forcing a foreign religion on these
people i mean it turns out christianity
was really really important to their
lives and that's fine
and what i found was that the the
anglicans and the catholics
whose missionaries had been there since
the late 19th century
but had never really converted people
very successfully until about the 1960s
and 70s for various reasons
um had a very sort of accommodating view
of of the old rituals you know
as far as they were concerned uh the old
rituals
um worship the same god so they used the
same term
which was you know the power was the
animus word for the supreme god and the
ba has become the
the sort of catholic and anglican word
for god the father
um the the practitioners weren't doing
anything bad
i mean if you were doing anything bad
you got you got into a lot of trouble
because people were very aware of kind
of black magic but
you know as far as they were concerned
most of the old rituals were were
designed to bring good things to the
village and bless the villagers
inhabitants so
no big deal right you just you just sort
of carry on helping them um and they
also saw it as
an important kind of familial or um
neighborly obligation to to help these
older villagers so it was very much
you know a way of kind of cementing
their existing social ties
with people who as far as they were
concerned needed help so
anytime you went to one of these rituals
in the village you would find your 10
animus practitioners doing their thing
you know doing the main chants and the
offerings and dances and everything
but all around them would be christians
and the christians would be there
building the altars for them you know
going up to the jungle to collect the
bamboo that they needed for these things
cooking the offerings killing the
sacrificial pigs
playing the gongs everything and they
saw this as a really important part of
their their kind of duty
the kind of the people who didn't agree
with this
were um members of the
evangelical church so this is the
siddang ingel borneo um it's a sort of
homegrown um non-denominational
evangelical church which some of you may
have heard of
um these guys um arrived in the village
in the 1990s and and their first
converts were converts from anglicanism
and catholicism so there's already a bit
of tension there
in that the church was seen as kind of
poaching you know some of the existing
christians and making them convert to a
different
a different sort of christianity um they
had a very they had a much more kind of
puritanical view of you know what was
and wasn't acceptable no drinking
uh no smoking no gambling which was big
it was a big sort of lubricant of
sociality in the village which all the
catholics and anglicans did
um and they and they were really
terrified i mean i think they were
actually quite scared of the old rituals
in the sense that they saw them as the
work of satan that would bring evil
spirits into the village
and so whenever these these rituals took
place you know there was always trouble
because
um any time the old practitioners came
into contact with the sib
the evangelicals they get a really sort
of aggressive reception and many
eventuals were often trying to
convert them um you know tell them that
they were going to hell and you know
they
their souls would not get to heaven and
it was all going to be horrible
um and so that was one really
interesting kind of you know local
heterogeneity that i hadn't really
expected to come across
um when i was actually doing field work
but but which became quite a defining
feature
of my understanding of village
christianity um and of course the same
thing you know the same thing applies to
what people thought of the old spirits
um nobody could could decide what would
actually happen to the old spirits and
how exactly to engage with them so there
was some
there were some people who um you know
especially the older ones if they'd
grown up
knowing how to deal with oats with the
old spirits if they encountered them in
the forest or in the village
they would just do the old things and
then say a christian prayer at the end
just to be safe
there were younger younger adults who
would do a kind of half-hearted
response as they should and then say a
prayer just to be safe
and then there were younger adults who
just refused to know in many cases you
know they they actually actively
cultivated a kind of agnosis or kind of
not knowing
precisely because they were really um
they really didn't want to sort of
end up acquiring the sort of knowledge
that would be necessary for them to
engage in these relations with the old
spirits because
you know the principle was once you knew
what to do if a spirit tried to talk to
you or send you a message and you didn't
actually do it you were going to be in
really deep trouble
and so um you know a lot of the the
younger people
like well actually you know what i don't
want to know about this
um which in turn meant they never wanted
to talk to me about it so i'd be you
know i'd be there with my notebook
oh my god you wouldn't believe what i've
just heard about this and
the old people didn't tell me that much
either because they didn't want to get
me into trouble right they were like
you're already useless right you can't
weave baskets you can't plant rice very
well
i'm not going to tell you how to deal
with these spirits no no no no i'm just
going to tell you
you know really sort of generic stuff so
i write down very generic stuff so
they're kind of protecting me
but you know the moment i go and talk to
some of the younger people they're just
like that
no no no not interested um so there's a
whole kind of spectrum
um of different ways of relating or in
this case actually not relating to the
old spirits that again you know it's
really interesting stuff but
if you take a sort of ontological turn
approach to it you're not going to
capture any of this stuff because you're
going to be running with the most
exciting
um point where you know it's about this
spirit concept and then
you kind of run off with this concept
but you're not going to capture that
heterogeneity
that's that's really fascinating in some
ways you foreclose what you're able to
look into because you're looking for
alterity
um whereas the the most important story
might be right there in front of your
nose
we're running close to the time i wanted
to a lot to our conversation but i want
to make sure that you
say a few words about your new research
on
orangutan conservation so if you could
speak for a few minutes about that just
to share that with our audience
and then after that i'll turn and
moderate uh
open question and answer with the with
the rest of the people who've come today
yeah okay um so um i i think i've very
briefly touched on what my two projects
in orangutan conservation are doing um
maybe what i could do is share a little
bit about what what we're currently
finding so
we're basically in the middle of these
projects um
most of us have kind of finished uh most
of our field
there was a bit of disruption due to
copious so we're not quite there yet but
um we've got some really interesting
initial insights um
so as i said uh i've got one two three
three colleagues who are currently
looking into human orangutan relations
or actually the lag thereof
on the ground in rural borneo and one of
the really interesting things we found
is this
very marked contrast between the sort of
hyper visibility of
orangutans you know in the west as these
very charismatic very famous
icons of extinction you think extinction
rainforests bang orangutans again
and um and then on the other side
in places like borneo and sumatra you've
got their relative invisibility and
insignificance and and what we tend to
find is that
for the most part rural villages in
borneo especially um we haven't done
that much work in sumatra yet but we're
getting similar um
input from people we know there for the
most part villagers are just not
interested in orangutans um you know
they're kind of
they're things that you might encounter
in the forest occasionally
but they're not particularly special um
they're not particularly creatures that
you want to form any relations with
every now and then they turn into these
pests because you know when it's durian
season and the trees are all fruiting
out come the orangutans um and so my phd
student paul actually had some really
interesting kind of
uh notes from his conversations with
farmers apparently orangutans are seen
as particularly naughty because
um you know when they when they raid
durian trees they don't just eat the
durians which is completely
understandable you know villages like
eating durians too
they throw the unripe durians onto the
ground which is really antisocial
so you know they so so by and large
peoples they're not companion species
let's put it this way in
any sense of the term you know for the
most part there was just no interest in
orangutans
their occasional pests you don't like
having them around what is interesting
though is that
the main ways in which orangutans become
visible and significant
uh to people in these places is through
conservation
so in many ways what we're finding is
that our field work actually
involves very little sort of physical um
encounters with orangutans very little
kind of evidence of human orangutan
relations necessarily
apart from pet keeping which i'll talk
about in a second um
and actually much more you know it's
much more to do with
villages relations with conservationists
who are in many ways making the
orangutans much more kind of
significant and and in a way much more
dangerous
um than they used to be in the past
because orangutans are protected and
people are aware that they're protected
and that you could get into a lot of
trouble
um for harming or capturing an orangutan
um
which you know for the most part you
just never seen as particularly
important or special or worth protecting
and so what we're kind of seeing emerge
here is is
quite a significant amount of tension um
between
people in in borneo especially um and
conservationists who are very often seen
as caring more about animals
than than people so you know you kind of
hear things like well you know
we are the real orangutan yeah the real
people of the forest
but why are they why are these
foreigners you know throwing all this
money
and and care and everything at saving
these
this this kind of this one eight right
why why just this one eight
why are you building these huge
rehabilitation centers with
state-of-the-art
x-rays you know medical supplies nappies
milk powder when we don't even have this
stuff
so um it's a really kind of tense
situation on the ground
um there's a whole kind of spectrum of
different conservationists um
as well so that kind of adds to the
complexity of things
um but i guess that that sort of tension
has really
been the the kind of main feature of our
field work in these areas
um i just want to touch very briefly on
this issue of pet keeping as well which
is
um in that article that i sent you um
there is kind of one exception to this
lack of interest in orangutans um
or you know kind of antagonism towards
orangutans and that's pet keeping that's
when
you know rural villages very often you
know the mother orangutan is killed um
while trying to get fruit or whatever or
in somebody's farm
they take the baby as a pet people are
aware that you can sell the pet for
quite a lot of money but some villagers
just choose to keep pets
um as pets um and it's not very common
and it's quite dispersed but it does
happen
um and in these cases um what we tend to
find is that these villages
see themselves as as kind of caring
carers of
orangutans so they see themselves as
having save these poor babies who are
completely helpless from a very cruel
jungle
where they might get eaten or killed or
die of starvation which is probably true
um you know they see themselves as kind
of investing into these these creatures
nurturing them feeding them paying money
for them buying them nappies whatever
um and so they're not as far as they're
concerned they're not harming them but
then
you know once conservationists become
aware of this fact
um this often results in in quite a kind
of dramatic
orangutan confiscation operation where
these conservationists will turn up um
[Music]
with members of the local wildlife and
forest authorities because it's always
going to be a member of the government
with them they turn up they confiscate
this orangutan they never they don't
offer compensation because as far as
they're concerned it's illegal
and then they take them to these
rehabilitation centers where they get
cared for they get fed they get cuddled
um you know they get nurtured
as far as villages are concerned in much
the same way as as they were doing it in
the village
um and so this is you know one of those
really interesting um
kind of ethical dilemmas i think that um
that that's been haunting me during my
research um and so you know just very
briefly
i think there's sort of three main
ethical concerns that
that kind of smash up against each other
here um you know one of them is
the sort of cultural relativist impulse
that many anthropologists
um are animated by right i mean you know
my my first reaction was like well
why shouldn't these people be allowed to
have whatever relations they want with
orangutans you know why not you know
this is this is colonialism this is bad
and then you've got that the whole sort
of um
cons well which comes into the sort of
more than human turn which i realized i
didn't really talk about but this is
part of the sort of multi-species tone
and anthropology where you start to
think about animals as agents and
animals as kind of
beings with with affective ties to
humans and you think
okay what if that you know you watch
some of these pet videos pet
confiscation videos and
the baby orangutan obviously doesn't
want to leave it's owner and you think
oh no
you know what about the the the the
feelings of this poor orangutan why
should why should it be put through this
traumatic separation
and then the third the third sort of
problem is that um
you know the main problem is that in
reality this sort of pet keeping can be
extremely damaging
um villagers don't tend to know how to
take care of orangutans they they feed
them rice condensed milk you know
chocolates um very often they end up
getting malnourished or ill they become
too big to control they get chained up
you know shoved into really crappy boxes
and actually you know in that case i
think the conservationists are right
they're actually
saving the orangutan from what could be
a really really nasty fate much later on
um and there's no resolution to these
impulses but you know that's kind of one
example of
the kinds of ethical dilemmas that um
our research is also trying to
foreground anyway i've spoken a lot so
i'm going to stop
well thank you you've spoken a lot but
you've given us a lot to think about um
and i'm sure that our audience has a lot
of questions for you so
what we'll do here is i'll moderate the
questions
um using the zoom interface so those of
you who have any questions
if you can use the hand raise function
that will help me out but if you can't
use the hand raised function
turn on your um camera and wave your
hand wildly and i'll try my best to
notice you
i see that michael dove has his hand up
using the hand raised function so we'll
start with michael go ahead michael
thanks eric a fascinating chat
which i've immensely enjoyed i wonder if
we could go back
right to the beginning when you talked
about
your work with the bidayu
in transition so i'm wondering
were the badayou ever not in transition
but borneo has has a very rich history
and it almost to to talk about
transition and pre-transition almost
sounds like
we're talking about a period of no
history
yeah thank you i mean i should clarify
that um
i'm talking about one of many many
transitional periods that the days have
gone through
um so people people talked about it as a
significant period of
change and that was kind of the sort of
local lingo that
that i was picking up on this idea of
marui which is
really quite fundamental sort of
transformation of their society and it
was i mean it was quite interesting that
um i mean absolutely from a kind of
analytical point of view i'm completely
with you they've always been in
transition and they've always engaged
with
um you know wider forces um in the world
that you know they they engaged with
um wider trade networks um for centuries
before that they were very much some of
the earliest supporters of the brook
state which was interesting they've been
some really interesting sort of
analyses of the relationships that they
formed um
with the with the government and later
the british colonial government so
they've been going through various
stages of transition i guess um i mean
maybe transition
isn't even the best word because you
know this is very much part of a
continuum of engaging with various
um external you know foreign regional
local um forces and agents um the reason
i described it as a transition was you
know as i said
um my attempt to mirror what i used
themselves were describing as
a major change in their lives and this
major change was conversion to
christianity as far as they were
concerned this was
this was huge and it entailed a much a
much more sort of fundamental overhaul
of their social relations and their kind
of cosmologies
and religious practices than some of
their other
engagements with outside forces did
you know for example with missionaries
who were hanging around in the area in
the 19th century and early 20th century
but who never converted them
so in that sense it was my attempt to
also capture what people
saw as a significant period of change
leading to the present but you know i'm
absolutely with you they've
you know there never was a kind of
static um
originally romantic past they've always
engaged with with
the world in various ways
thank you thanks lyanna the next
question is from al lim who's a phd
student
in the anthropology department here at
yale
um hi liana thank you so much for your
presentation
it's super fascinating to think about
the ways people rationalize
um these kinds of displacement um i'm
thinking about eric's own work in
vietnam
and kind of work in in the mekong and
and the mid sun and
and just across asia so but with
specific kind of question about your
site you talk about
in in your article um gifting damning
and the ambiguation of
development um this kind of christian
framework that trumps um
be to use allegiance to the malaysia's
development state so i'm wondering this
kind of syncretism is it
a mode of resistance or is it a coping
mechanism and how might this
have changed over time so you talked
about the kind of planning phase
of the the during phase and the post
phase so i'm just wondering how this
kind of
mode of rationalization changes over
time and i know you wrote the durian
piece at the end so i was wondering if
you could speak a little bit to that as
well thank you
okay wow okay thank you um
yeah i i don't really know if it's a
sort of resistance or coping mechanism i
mean in a way i'm trying to refrain you
know i'm doing my own ambiguation in the
sense that i'm trying to refrain from
um saying well this this is the
explanation this this is basically the
function that it's serving
um i guess the point of that that piece
um was to was to try and reverse the
usual way that we tend to view
um uh sort of people's engagements with
development projects so rather than
trying to use something like a sort of
fukodian you know governmental
governmentality lens to understand how
people become subjects of development um
i try to kind of reverse and say okay
how does development become
christianized how does it become
mythologized
um looking through these sort of
indigenous ideas and you know i i would
consider christianity indigenous
in its own way it's it's become a
significant cultural concept
um and i guess if i had to if
you sort of pin me down i'd probably say
that christianity is a sort of creative
mechanism
more than anything else it's been it's
been an incredibly sort of powerful
means through which uh my interlocutors
have
managed to create realities for
themselves um in ways that
were previously inconceivable within the
framework of the sort of malaysian
developmental estate so
um i've actually currently got an
article that's it's just been accepted
in current anthropology
um and it's looking at it basically
looks at the sort of christian
dimensions of this
legal case that they fought and um you
know tries to understand
um how for many of you know even though
the case itself was sort of
was fought in in legal in the terms of
indigenous rights and sort of legal
rights
behind the scenes it was all about god
it was all about them being good moral
christians and trying to
enact um you know a sort of politically
engaged form of christianity in the
world which
in fact kind of led them to to desert
the anglican church on mass and move to
this west malaysian
charismatic church because they thought
the anglican church was just kind of too
tied up with the state
um and and god was a big player in this
right so it became a very sort of
powerful productive force through which
they could actually make this
new this new village above the dam a
reality and as far as they were
concerned this was this was god's doing
i mean the lawyers helped but this was
definitely you know a big cosmological
fight that they won because they were
good christians
um so i guess that's uh that's one way
of
you know kind of rethinking development
um yeah the durian piece so
you talking about durian diplomacies
yeah yeah yeah so um so
so what's happened right just to bring
you up to up to date is that
these these guys eventually won the
right to
to well it's a bit tricky so they they
got they forced the state to recognize
their ancestral rights to the land above
the dam
um unfortunately the state refuse still
refuses to recognize
the their right to have a village on
that site which was kind of that point
right so they went and built this
village from scratch before they even
won the case
and they're living there now but because
the state is not supporting it you know
it's refused to give it subsidies for
pesticides you know
none of the usual solar power panel
solar panels um
money for bamboo water pipe systems
anything they're trying to have
they become sort of entrepreneurial and
they're they've always been
entrepreneurial they've always been
you know been selling pepper and rubber
and cocoa depending on what the prices
are like but
they're kind of striking out on their
own right now which is really really
really interesting
and one of the things that they've done
is they've worked with this daoke so
this
chinese businessman um you know who has
a durian plantation
selling uh growing musang king which
like it's a sort of premium brand of
durian
that the china market pays a huge amount
of money for
um he has this plantation up in cameron
highlands and because these guys are up
in the hills
he's got them to transplant some of
these musang king seedlings
uh over to their land and they're
growing these musang king
durians and and uh marrying them with
the local variant as they say so that
they all become this kind of super
hybrid um
you know kind of indigenous durians um
and the hope is that they'll eventually
um sell these durians uh to the chinese
market and and make a lot of money
um so that that's a new sort of strategy
that they're using um
to make the most of their current
situation
thank you lyanna we have a question from
ling zhang
um ling jong do you mind introducing
yourself also before you ask your
question
sure thank you thank you so much for
this wonderful talk
hi jim um and i'm not an anthropologist
i'm
actually a historian for china i
i'm working on environmental history so
your talk is
fascinating it teaches me a lot about
the ongoing uh discourses in your
discipline in your field so
um i'm i i entered this conversation
a few minutes later so you might have
already touched upon this i noticed in
the talk
in the com in the title of your talk
there is
dance there so i might have missed the
conversation about that can you say
something
about dance and also i noticed in your
talk
and in several of your publications you
mentioned
troubled landscapes so could you please
also say something about the troubled
landscapes what do you mean and
related to dams and the troubled
landscape
then this lead to another issue i'm
very curious about um that's something
um here what is
the how do anthropologists
like you working on more than human
and multi-species issue to incorporate
non-life forms let's say
dams let's say gigantic concrete
monsters
non-organic beings
how do you deal with that not
necessarily not
necessarily life-based not necessarily
species based so i'm just purely curious
about what's the conversation in your
field about that
thank you yeah wow thank you so much
yeah um
i think they're sort of they're all very
much connected
yeah i mean in some ways you know it
feels like multi-species
as a as a kind of approach isn't
necessarily expensive enough
to incorporate um everything that we
want to talk about and so that's that's
why i use the term more than human
rather than multi-species because um you
know a lot of my work has been has
involved trying to understand this
incredibly sort of powerful and really
quite problematic
um uh agency i guess that these
non-living beings can have
uh on people's lives and how they kind
of co-create these sorts of realities
um and so this kind of brings me to the
notion of dams and troubled landscapes
um so that
these are these are basically connected
in the sense that um my paper troubled
landscapes was very much
an attempt to understand um how
effectively my interlocutors were
becoming displaced
from their own landscape their own kind
of um
sort of genealogical social moral
uh space which they called abbotta which
means basically our
area without ever having left it um and
this was
that was where the sort of troubled-ness
came in right that they were still
living in this space
that was undergoing these really quite
radical and far-reaching
physical changes um that then had
implications for the way they related to
the land so
um you know so in this in this article
um i wrote about how
um prior to to the dam coming along they
sort of
they sort of use things like fruit trees
and landmarks and and kind of
bamboo you know rows of bamboo old old
um longhouse posts as um sort of indexes
of their their genealogies and their
movements in the sort of migration
patterns across that land
which could in turn be ways of
understanding um people's rights and
relationships and kinship obligations in
the present
um and of course once the dam came along
and the landscape began being
began being kind of reshaped in
anticipation of inundation
all that started to disappear really
quickly um so
you know you didn't just have this
sudden
damn landscape that was opening up um in
front of them which they had to walk
through it took i mean it would take
about an hour sometimes when the weather
was bad to get through these
this construction site and it was
absolutely terrifying you know you'd
have boulders kind of
falling down occasionally you'd have
these burst water pipes you'd have these
yeah these huge machines that you'd have
to somehow pick your way around
and you know people would always talk
about these things as if they had a kind
of malign
agency and force in themselves you know
so and so you know
one of those workers fell off that water
tower or whatever recently
broke open his head they buried him they
didn't know where he came from
you know you get all these stories as
you were kind of walking through um
through the damn construction site um so
so
i guess in that sense you know what was
happening was this really weird
this weird sort of process of
displacement that didn't involve
necessarily a kind of relocation
or migration to a different site but
that was nevertheless completely
reshaping
um people's lives so that's kind of what
i meant and yeah i mean absolutely the
dam
the dam was a huge thing you know not
just a sort of big physical cement
structure which is
big um but also it's it's it's specter
it's possibility
which which you know changed things and
people's relations way before the waters
ever came and then when the waters came
it was all about how they were stinky
and deadly and toxic
and i mean yeah there were many many
sort of affective and very visceral
associations
produced by these non-human things
including dams
so yeah i don't think multi-species is
necessarily a big enough term to capture
what was going on
right so in the sense the trouble
landscape creates many new spirits
too in this new era sounds like
yeah i think so i think so i think we're
still working that one out i mean i know
it upset many old spirits
so there were hauntings in the in the
dormitory that we heard about a lot
um it was all about the old waterways
getting blocked up and spirits getting
really pissed off about that
yeah there was all that going on as well
um they might i think they said there
might be hauntings by the spirits of the
workers who died
but i haven't heard anything since then
so i don't know if that's still
if that's thank you so much thank you
um i believe we have a question from jim
scott and then after
jim we have a question from ayesha
kashani shoko yamada and kristin
s um and we have about 20 minutes left
it's one o'clock for those of you who
have to leave at one o'clock sometime
but we have a i'm we can stick around a
little longer so i'll let jim take the
question and then we'll turn to the
other
go ahead jim thanks a lot it was a
wonderful talk
um and provocative um
what i want to ask you to speculate
about
is the relationship between
monotheism as an
anthropological reality on the ground
not in turn not in terms of its books
and doctrine
but islam or christianity especially the
hard-edged version that's
recently come and its relationship
to the non-human world generally i mean
one of the
from an abstract perspective one of the
attractions i think to environmentalists
of animism is the presumption
that the non-human world has
agency spirit and so on
and therefore uh demands a certain kind
of respect
i know faiza zacharia was a colleague of
yours
in history uh at naos is working on
these issues in sumatra but i'd like you
to
say something about monotheism
on the ground as it's understood and
practiced
and whether it's relationship to the
non-human world
is different radically different
moderately different
from let's say the older
spirit loving uh practitioners
at your field site
interesting thank you very much for
putting that thought in my head
um i'm
it's hard it's hard for me to say
whether or not
the the christians i'm familiar with
have a particularly strong concept of
monotheism i think they're sort of
they're very aware that the christian
god
so i'm really speaking from from this
underground experience here they're very
aware that the christian god
is the most you know it is the one true
god but that doesn't necessarily make
him the only god
um so as i think as far as they're
concerned the
the sort of one of the biggest
attractions of christianity
when people initially converted was that
it was seen to free and they used the
the term bia which means which is a
ritual term it means
free from a ritual taboo to free bidet
use
from the sort of obligations and
difficulties and challenges and
hardships
that were caused by the old animist
rituals
now it's very hard to tell whether this
is a kind of retrospective glass that
people
put on the old animus rituals as a way
of kind of justifying their conversion
to christianity but the sort of standard
story that you hear is
in the olden days things were really
hard because the spirits were really
unpredictable
there were lots of pantone you know lots
of taboos that you might come across
um if you were walking to the farm and
you had a busy day's work harvesting the
rice if you saw a bird flying past you
three times in a certain direction oh no
you'd have to stop immediately because
that was an omen and you'd be punished
if you didn't obey it
and so people often talked about these
very sort of unpredictable but also very
kind of
um time-consuming restrictions that they
had to live with
in the old days as one of the main
reasons that they chose to convert
to convert to christianity they were
free and and the reason they were free
was not that
they didn't believe the old spirits
existed anymore it was that they
they realized that the old spirits were
now being trumped by a more powerful
spirit which was god or jesus or mary or
whatever and they had weapons they had
you know crucifixes altars
um holy water and so on uh with which
they could kind of combat
any malign influences and whether it was
satan or whether it was the old spirits
that were causing trouble for them so i
mean it's hard to say whether there is a
you know that that is a form of
monotheism on the ground i suppose in
the sense that
you know theoretically i think everyone
subscribes to a
relatively purified model of
christianity you know they they will
they will say the right things and they
they know in theory what the story they
call it stories
is meant to be about in practice
i think it's a much more difficult sort
of juggling act between
um you know the sort of realities of the
christian present and the
the continued the persistent remnants of
the pre-christian past that
that us i mean they're just there you
know they're not even they're not even
possibilities they're just there in in
people's lives
um and so i guess you know sort of
relating this point to
the non-human world i think maybe one of
the
one of the things that i find
environmentalists tend to get wrong
it's kind of this assumption that all
indigenous people
love and care about and have kin
relations with
and so on um
[Music]
uh non-human beings um
i don't think that's necessarily true i
mean when you sort of look at
these sorts of relations on the ground
we find that people were just as
interested in drawing boundaries
and um and and very you know often
people would have kind of antagonistic
relations
um with certain beings and certain
animals certain parts of nature
however you define that um and
so i'm not sure necessarily if
christianity might have enacted a change
so much as that
that stereotype about indigenous
may not be all that true
um i'm generalizing a little bit here
but you know certainly from what i've
seen
um in in in the borneo context
um that's that's not the case there's a
much more kind of complex range of
emotions and relations and boundaries
that you see in people's relations with
non-human spirits and
non-human animals
great um we'll move to the next question
from ayesha kashani
hi hi liana thank you for the time um
yeah i mean okay so i'm a phd student at
goldsmiths university of london and
visual cultures and my work's looking at
cosmopolitics and the histories and
futures of exhibiting nature at the
cerral
museum and so i just wanted to ask i
mean about your reference to cosmic
politics
um if you can speak a little bit to the
methodologies and practices that you're
working with in terms of mediating
between conservationists
and communities and orangutans and the
state and everything else
and how if you are using a kind of
cosmic political framework in terms of
negotiating between those
and how it's working out yeah
um i think i use it sort of selectively
um so uh i mean there are obviously sort
of different approaches to cosmopolitics
um the one that i'm finding most useful
at this point
is um you know the one that's used by
marisol de la cadena and her colleague
um mario blaser um in relation to sort
of indigenous groups in north and south
america
and and what these are sort of built
around are a kind of ontological
turnish desire to try and take their
spirit beliefs their relations with
things like um you know mountains
important mountains um other spirits
again on ontological terms um and to
actually
uh you know rather than kind of
explaining them away as just beliefs or
kind of cultural glosses or
superstitions trying to understand the
sort of political role
that these these non-human entities can
play in
in their politics and their relations
with the state um and i think the sort
of main thing that i take away from this
particular body of work is that it it
advocates an approach to
to difference um and incommensurability
quite specifically
um that does not uh go
for that does not go for a kind of
hybrid or neutralizing end right so if
you get say four different kind of you
know incremental
um complexes practices people together
um what they sort of advocate as a way
for them to to kind of
come together through partial
connections so this is what de la cadena
are drawing on marilyn strathern
um uses um but without allowing any
party to encompass or dominate
or you know run over the other such that
that original difference is
preserved is maintained so it's it's a
kind of
it's it's a sort of alignment and a way
forward momentarily
without nullifying the original the
original difference
and i think that is actually a very
useful approach um you know in various
ways too
particularly to orangutan conservation
where you know you've constantly got
conservationists and the state trying to
change mindsets this is a very
popular phrase in orangutan conservation
you know it's always like
how do we change these villages mindsets
how do we change these indigenous
peoples mindsets and
you know get them to love orangutans for
example and and i guess one of the
things i've been trying to you know
encourage
conservationists to think about is how
they can adopt a slightly more
cosmopolitan
approach to this you know rather than
trying to
completely change the way um these rural
villages think about orangutans for
example
um you know can you sort of find ways
through that
that don't involve forcing them to adapt
to your particular values or your
particular
um you know assumptions about sort of
human human animal relations about
about how special orangutans are um
and actually what i might do is very
quickly respond to michael's
um comment uh in the text because this
is relevant
um this was um the the orangutan was
kind of
tabooed um in certain parts of borneo
but as far as i can
as far as i know it was not across the
entire island so
um i do know that there there have been
various 19th century early 20th century
sources and some contemporary stories um
particularly among
various ebon communities as you say
about how
it has a special relationship to
contemporary um
villages particularly in the way um it
was said it was said to um
to teach humans how to give birth uh
safely so the idea was that you know
there's an iban guy who went out to the
forest
um saw an orangutan mother being helped
to to give birth by other children
and that persuaded the iban man to stop
um the old practice of apparently
cutting open women's stomachs when they
gave birth which was probably quite bad
and adopt this method of helping to
massage out and the child
so there are certain villages um in
which historically
um the orangutan was a special and taboo
creature
but that's not as far as i can tell
widespread across borneo
uh and it's not called it's not
necessarily uh
different to any other um village's
special relation with other animals so
it may not be an orangutan it might be a
snake or a crocodile or
a particular bird or something else um
and again you know to go back to aisha's
point
this is where it is quite important to
try and avoid um
sort of stereotypical or generalized
views about the kind of difference that
you're trying to overcome as a
conservationist
you know there are many conservationists
who who jump on this idea of the
orangutan as a tabooed
animal as a special animal to very very
specific communities iban communities
in the past and they say well we want to
help them remember
their old rituals let's do it um
and i guess my question is you know is
there sort of a better way of doing this
that somehow allows them
respects that difference and allows them
to sort of find a way through
um without trying to nullify their
distinctiveness
um i see that jim wanted to jump in
jim you had your hand up really quick is
it did you have something you wanted to
jump in
or can i jump to shoko and kristin
okay ashoka yamada who's a phd student
in the anthropology
and school of environment here at yale
has a question
hi um thank you so much for this talk i
was fascinating
fascinated throughout and i especially
loved the example you were talking about
in terms of
um the heterogeneity of ontology how
there's like not a single
ontology that you could talk about on
the ground um and i was thinking about
in relation to
maybe michael's earlier question about
um transition and borneo being in
transition and the fact that
when you're doing field work a lot of
people are going through conversion to
christianity or relatively recently
and going to going through this change
um and i was thinking about how
um maybe we could think about that as
like another form of heterogeneity
almost across
um not in terms of like space where like
lots of people disagreeing about stuff
and debating about things but
kind of a heterozygous across time um
within you know this supposedly
um same single self um so i was
i guess i have two related questions on
this one is just
on the ground how um people are living
through and grappling with this kind of
transition or maybe
um like whether whether you or i guess
how
like whether um there's a sense of
contradiction is there a sense of
nostalgia
towards um a different kind of past or
is it is this seen as progress i'm just
kind of curious how
um ethnographically how people are
dealing with this and
and the second one is i guess a little
more um
a theoretical one in terms of your
critique of
the ontological turn and um how
um and kind of i guess the question
about how the term i
or might not be able to deal with um
this kind of historical change over time
um and yeah so i was kind of wondering
if you could speak about that and and
how
you are i guess suggestion to deal with
more of the core presence between the
ethnographers and and the interlocutors
as opposed to kind of the radical
authority might or might not help us um
kind of deal with this kind of change
that the term might or might not miss
um yeah those are it's a lot but
yeah if you could speak any us speak to
any aspect of that
yeah thank you very much i mean that's a
yeah that that's a really nice way of
articulating it thank you
um yeah uh heterogeneity across time um
that that's a really good point um and i
mean they've been sort of various
critiques of the ontological term that
that you know kind of also point out how
they're not necessarily
very helpful when it comes to you know
dealing with with the ways in which
people's
views or approaches or selves and
relations might change over time so i
think you're absolutely right
um how are people living through
transition um
yeah um one way
which i which i find really interesting
and which which also in some ways kind
of um
prodded my my kind of uh you know
anti-colonial sensibilities i guess
one one thing i found really interesting
is that there's been a kind of um
[Music]
romanticization of
the the british pass
zaman british
as they say and by british uh vida used
tend to mean both the british colonial
government
and the the brook raj which was a
curious beast um that ruled sarawak
um in in the century before that um and
what is interesting
here is that there is a kind of
nostalgia
developing around how in the olden days
the british would uh would care for
they were kindly women this kind
generous they would care for
um people like themselves because they
wouldn't eat their land
right this is the term they use they
don't the british did not eat our land
and they gave us some development they
gave us rubber plantations
they gave us water tanks they brought
christianity who brought education and
and medicines and this is then used as a
kind of um
uh moral foil to um the contemporary
malaysian government which they see as
only ever wanting to eat their lands
um and you know the fear of land grabs
is quite sort of justified in in sarawak
um and also withholding development from
them because they're not
muslim um and so there's a really
interesting kind of
you know it's almost like a sort of
dialectic here where you've kind of got
this this
romanticized um brook british past set
against
um what they see is a very very
unpleasant reality of of a sort of
malaysian present
and i suppose what's really interesting
about this
[Music]
and i guess this sort of goes back to
this question of co-presence and
historicity as well is that
what i think i think what they're what
people are invoking here
is not so much um
a sort of absolutely good british past
but a kind of ideal relationship with a
benevolent state which they've kind of
come to see as a baseline so as far as
they're concerned you know the the
british
government as they say kind of laid the
it set the standards for what
their relationship with the state should
be like the state should take care of
them but it should not eat their lands
and what they want from the malaysian
government as a return to that
relationship
give us development but don't take our
lands
um and there's a there's an interesting
sort of constant hopefulness
about the way they they sort of engage
with politicians and with development
projects that they think well maybe this
will work you know maybe maybe this time
um this project might actually give us
development and work
and and still allow us to keep our land
so this is there's a very interesting
kind of
you know eternal optimism at play here
that comes with that nostalgia i think
um and so i guess they've got their own
sort of um projections right they've got
their own sort of future
speculative projects about how at some
point they will return to this this kind
of ideal government this ideal
um bw state relationship um
and i think that is particularly
interesting um
because that is them trying to project
themselves um
into what i described earlier as a very
powerful homogenizing force
um you know it's them basically saying
well we don't want to be completely
eaten up by the malaysian state but we
really do want to be malaysian you know
we really do believe in being
malaysian citizens and we want our
rights we want we want the development
and the other good things that we do
um so please don't forget us um and that
is a form of co-presence that they're
constantly asserting but also a form of
sameness
um which i find you know a really
interesting kind of
idea to deal with i guess because partly
because it sort of
it probably sort of pushes up against
you know my own kind of
anthropological instincts which is you
know why why do you want to do this
um but you know i guess it's i guess
it's pragmatic you know they want to be
malaysians they want to be part of the
state
um that's sort of my job to try and
understand
how and why
thank you liana um leon we're getting
close to 120. i have time but i am
mindful of
i didn't tell you how long we would keep
you and if you have the energy you can
answer as long as you
wish but um we have two more questions
to that i'd like to hear
um would you like to hear both questions
at the same time or should i go one at a
time
oh i don't mind um it's okay so we'll
we'll go with kristin s
first and kristen if you can introduce
yourself
hello thank you very much uh
i'm i wanted to ask you
about to reflect a little bit um
if possible what seemed we
we seem to be so comfortable glossing
over
the influence of
christianity um and this homogenizing
force that you speak
of um and even in the way in which
it contributes to this shaping of a view
of what the relationship with the state
should be
um and that you know all of
our understanding um
currently suggests that the great
importance of biodiversity of of
um and how do we
it's so troubling to me to hear
the way in which you describe young
people
not wanting to have even to be have any
understanding of their origin
of their cultural identity because
they've been
so um
brainwashed i just to believe that
somehow this is going to be detrimental
to them
and and why is it that we have this
notion
that somehow crucifixes and
are valid tools for protection um
and that and and how is it that we we
become as academics often so comfortable
with
um this dispassionate observation
of um the loss of a language of a
of a whole body of knowledge this
hierarchical
valuing of what is
the gift of understanding that we're
bringing in education and the arrogance
that we show
in in in not
um how do we overcome
this sense of uh trying to
actually learn from
cultures that have been in existence for
thousands of years
very successfully and actually expand
our knowledge
as opposed to contracting it and making
it smaller
sure yeah no thank you um i mean i you
know i have to say this is something
that troubles me a lot as well um
and you know when i earlier on i kind of
said
i i went into this research very very
hostile towards missionaries and and
christianity precisely because of this
um this problem um but you know i think
this is where
this is where we do have one of those
sort of classic ethical tensions in
anthropology which which is actually
very very difficult to get around
um and this is this and that is this
question of how
of what you do if the people that you're
working with
fervently and wholeheartedly
subscribe to something and believe in
something and craft their lives around
something that you personally
might find repugnant or find extremely
problematic and you know
i do find christianity extremely
problematic in all sorts of ways
but i also acknowledge that if i
were to approach the field work that i
did
from that starting point i wouldn't have
been able to do field work
um in this village i would not have been
able to understand
very much about my interlocutors lives
um and so i guess yes i mean in this
case
um i did make a choice to suspend
you know my sort of personal concerns
about the influence and the very
detrimental influence that christianity
had
has had in in all sorts of societies and
to actually try to
understand what it was about
christianity
that was so powerful in people's lives
how how it was changing
their lives um and you know that that
was
that was basically something i had to do
in order to understand
um the people that i was living with um
i guess the other thing to sort of
say is that in many ways the young
people have embraced
um aspects of their past
the badayu language is not dying people
are still actively speaking in the
villages
it's busy you know people are busy um
recreating it and
um playing around with it um on social
media it's been absolutely fascinating
kind of watching
new kinds of terminology new spellings
emerge
on facebook with my friends um you know
where they really are kind of
it is still very much a living language
and there are also many other aspects of
kind of earlier
bits of um non-animist life that
um that have not completely been
squashed so you know
i think i think in that sense what what
they were very concerned about was a
very specific
aspect of the old ways which was
precisely how you relate to the old
spirits and how
that might actually cause trouble for
them how it might actually put them in
personal danger
and and this was a very deeply felt you
know concern it wasn't just
i don't want to know about my the old
ways because i'm christian now it was
kind of like you know
if i inadvertently screw up on this my
child could die
um and it was i didn't really feel that
it was my place to then come in there
and say well actually you're doing
things wrong because
you are disrespecting um your old you
know the old ways your old culture i
mean i certainly felt it
but it was not i felt my place to pass
that sort of judgment during my field
work
and so i did maintain a certain sort of
agnosticism
about what i was studying um and you
know trying to understand
um and i mean it was also very
interesting
that um the elderly practitioners were
very they're quite sort of blase about
it which i which i also found
interesting i said well you know
um life ways are changing all the times
rituals change
the old spirits are going to become
christian eventually or they might just
go off to their homes in the in the
hills and the rivers
um because you know we're always
changing um
so you know i guess it was that it was
that aspect of christian conversion that
i was trying to understand and how
actually this sort of christianity
this sort of christian life did come to
suffuse relations in the village
um yeah and and you know and it felt
uncomfortable at many points but
you know i guess in terms of trying to
actually empathize
and um understand my interlocutors lives
that was a kind of suspension of my own
doubt that i
had to take
thank you liana it reminded me of
something you said earlier too about
the when you were talking about ontology
about the the need to
have a kind of humility as an
anthropology or a humble
anthropology that you had talked about
before um we'll take the last question
from david lindsay
thank you thank you for this uh talk has
been very interesting
regarding the people you have focused on
are the older ways
in general more environmentally
conscious than the new
christian views do these people become
less or more environmentally conscious
with embracing christianity
um yeah that's a tough one to answer um
it's a tough one to answer because the
sort of big push to convert to
christianity
went hand in hand with a move away from
rice planting
um and so that you know
so there were for example and they still
are um
you know various kind of traditional
ways of
of i guess what we would now call them
sustainable
farming right which which people still
observe so you know for example there
was a
there are certain kind of areas of land
that are set aside for use by the
community
you know not not a single household
which is the usual unit of ownership but
a community
um and and people are allowed to sort of
take turns cultivating that piece of
land but then
you know the sort of general
understanding is that if the roon which
is like the spirit of the place
um finds that there's one family that's
been over cultivating it or doing too
much then it gets really cross and then
your crop fails
so you know just don't do that and
people are actually quite good at
following that you know they may or may
not say it's to do with the bhutaroon
now
even though they you know generally
there's an understanding that the puerto
rican still exists
um but they're generally quite good um
you know even you know including today
in christian villages at following that
rule so you could say in some ways that
actually it's not it's not really made a
huge difference
um i think the sort of bigger change has
been um
and just with sort of development and
and the extension of infrastructure to
these villages
um so the village where i did my phd had
a road built a tired road extended to it
in the sort of 19 late 1990s so it was
it was it had been a very sort of stony
gravel road before that
um and it was it was tired and and that
caused a huge demographic shift
in people effectively becoming um
village commuters
you know they go to school and work in
urban areas earn wages
they came back they lived in the village
they'd be villages
um and so that actually meant that they
most of them were not relying on um
on subsistence farming anymore so it was
you know you'd still have
people would still cultivate their land
because they were afraid of land grabs
so it was a kind of political point um
you know they didn't want the state to
come in and see these
seemingly unused or abandoned pieces of
land and say oh we're going to take
those
um you know it was very much a case of
no we're going to keep our lands going
even if we're never going to feed
ourselves from it
um so i mean it it's it's a tricky one
because
you know you can't really separate the
conversion to christianity from the
urbanization process
um in a way you know there's just been
much less done to the local environment
um since people have started converting
to christianity but that's nothing
that's got nothing to do with
christianity it's just got to do with
urbanization
yeah thank you well
thank you liana this has been a
fascinating conversation i
i really appreciate you taking so much
time with us today to share
so much about your long-term ongoing
research in borneo
i'm going to bring the session to a
close uh there is a
question for you in the chat that if you
want to respond
you can send me the answer and i'll send
it to to the the quest or
but i think it is now 1 30 so we should
bring it to
close so everyone join me in thanking
lyanna
for such a wonderful talk and we'll see
you in two weeks for a talk with jim
scott on the irawati and lyanna you're
welcome to join us for that if you're
interested
thank you very much it was lovely to
meet everyone sort of thank you
thank you